the realm
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns in A
Song of Ice and Fire update video what I
want to do today is go for some of the
things that George our Martin has had to
say about Game of Thrones as well as his
next book the winds of winter for the
most part George our Martin has stayed
relatively silent about the ending a
game of Thrones as well as when he
thinks the winds of winter will get
released over the years this has led to
many fans speculating about why they
think the winds of winter continues to
get delayed some say he was waiting for
Game of Thrones to end while others say
he will never release the next book also
he hasn't said a whole lot about what he
thinks of the final season a game of
Thrones
as you all know this universe is his
very own creation he has been writing a
song of ice and fire ever since the
1990s
when he finally agreed to let HBO adapt
his work into a television show he was
initially helping them bring it to life
on the screen every season he would even
write one of the episodes himself which
ended up becoming some of the best
episodes in this series like the Battle
of Blackwater Bay and the lion in the
Rose well it was right around a season
five when George started to distance
himself from the show that also happened
to be right around the same time when
the show was no longer following the
books ever since then he hasn't said
very much about the show this is one of
the many reasons why fans started to
think he was no longer liking the
direction the show was heading in well
now that it's finally over he did have
something to say I want to read exactly
what he wrote but like I said I also
want to read what he said about the
winds of winter now some of you may have
already seen this but I think most of
you will find it to be very interesting
like I did the very first thing I want
to look at is what was said about the
winds of winter since it has been
delayed so many times some think that
George was contractually obligated to
wait until Game of Thrones was over
before he could release it now this is
something that fans have been saying for
years but it wasn't until one of the
actors from Game of Thrones said it that
led to George actually having to come
out and address it because he did not
want everyone thinking that it was true
during an interview the actor who we all
knew as Barristan Selmy decided to say
this for whatever reason here's what he
had to say
George has already written book six and
seven George in the personal space and
as far as he is concerned thorough dr7
bonus for you or cc or C but he struck
an agreement with David and the
showrunners a series
geniuses that he would not
so as you can see this game of thrones
actor said George not only had the winds
of winter done but he also had a dream
of spring done which is said to be the
final book in the A Song of Ice and Fire
series as soon as fans heard this it
started to spread across the internet
like wildfire well it eventually made
its way to george RR martin and he was
not very happy about it now most of the
time he would not even acknowledge
something like this but since one of the
actor said it he felt like he should say
something before everyone starts to
believe it now let's look at what George
had to say internet journalism is an
oxymoron I am more and more convinced of
late it seems there's a new story about
me somewhere on the net everyday or near
enough to make no matter many get things
wrong for the most part I ignore them I
have better things to do than to try and
track down every weird rumor or out an
out fabric ation that pops up on some
obscure website trolling for traffic
every so often however one of those
stories gains an improbable currency and
just chuckling at the insanity no longer
suffices
that seems to be happening right now all
of a sudden this crazy story about me
finishing the winds of winter and a
dream of spurring years ago is popping
up everywhere no I am NOT going to
provide links I don't want to reward
purveyors of misinformation with hits I
will however say for the record no the
winds of winter in a dream of spring are
not finished dream has not even begun I
am NOT going to start writing volume 7
until I finish volume 6 it seems absurd
to me that I need to state this the
world is round the earth revolves around
the Sun water is wet do I need to say
that too it boggles me that anyone would
believe this story even for an instant
it makes not a whit a sense why would I
sit for years on completed novels why
would my publishers not just here in the
US but all around the world ever consent
to this they make millions and millions
of dollars every time a new Ice and Fire
book comes out as do i delaying makes no
sense
why would HBO want the books delayed the
books help create interest in the show
just as the show creates interest in the
books
no the books are not done HBO did not
ask me to delay them nor did David and
Dan there is no deal to hold back on the
books I assure you
HBO and David and Dan would both have
been thrilled and delighted if the winds
of winter had been delivered and
published four or five years ago and no
one would have been more delighted than
me I have said it before don't believe
everything you read on the Internet
except here of course so as you can see
he shot this down almost immediately the
actor who said it during the interview
most likely read something on the
internet then decided to say it because
it sounded reasonable enough we all
would like to think that he would have
had this book done by now if you look at
every other release date for his books
in the ax Song of Ice and Fire series it
has never taken him this long to finish
a book a game of Thrones first came out
back on August 1st 1996 he started
working on this story literally decades
ago the next book that came out a Clash
of Kings was released on November 16
1998 so from the time the first book
came out until the second book came out
there was only a two year in three month
gap then his next book a Storm of Swords
came out at the end of the year 2000 so
it was basically another two years to
finish another book now the next book a
feast for crows is when he really starts
to slow down a feast for crows doesn't
come out until the Year 2005 that is a
five-year wait for the next book then it
was almost six years until a dance with
dragons came out now we are waiting for
the winds of winter and this one has
taken longer than any of the other books
it has almost been eight years since the
dance of dragons came out so you can
kind of understand why some fans would
think that he has to be already done
well let's see what George had to say he
gave a winds of winter update only a few
days ago he starts off by saying I was
surprised last night when Air New
Zealand went to the Internet to invite
me down for a visit to help me finish my
book then he basically goes on to say
how he has been there before and how
much he loves to visit but at the very
end he does sort of give an update on
the status of the winds of winter he
says as for finishing my book I fear
that New Zealand would distract me
entirely too much best leave me here in
Westeros for the nonce but I tell you
this
I don't have the winds of winter in hand
when I arrived in New Zealand for
Worldcon you have my here formal written
permission to imprison me in a small
cabin on white island overlooking that
lake a sulfuric acid until I'm done just
so long as the acidic fumes do not screw
up my old dos word processor I'll be
fine
so what he more or less says is there is
no reason why he should not have the
winds of winter done by the end of the
next year now of course he has said very
similar things before he said he should
be done in 2015 2016 2017 but it
continued to get delayed every single
year however I myself am fairly
optimistic I do happen to think he is
very close to getting it done he hasn't
given himself a deadline in quite some
time so considering he is now saying
this I would like to believe him as we
all know the ending a game of Thrones
was so heavily criticized I think it may
have motivated him even more to get it
done soon so now that you have seen what
he said about the winds of winter let's
see what George said after Game of
Thrones was over he said the last night
the last show after eight epic seasons
HBO's Game of Thrones series has come to
an end it is hard to believe that it is
over if truth be told the years have
gone by in the blink of an eye can it
really have been more than a decade
since my manager set up a meeting at the
palm in LA and I sat down for the first
time with David Benioff and DB Weiss for
a lunch that lasted well past dinner I
did ask them if they knew who Jon Snow's
mother was fortunately they did that was
how it started it ended last night I had
no clue that afternoon at the poem that
I was about to embark on a journey that
would change my life I had optioned
books and stories for television and
film before and some had even been made
there was no way to know that this was
going to be different that this pilot
would not only be shot but would go on
to become the most successful show in
the history of HBO when a record number
of Emmy Awards and become the most
popular and most pirated show in the
world and transform a group of talented
but largely unknown actors into major
celebrities and stars even less that I
imagined that I would somehow become a
celebrity as well and if truth be told
I'm still not sure how that happened it
has been a wild ride to say the least I
want to thank people by
there are so many there were 42 cast
members at the season 8 premiere in New
York City and that wasn't even all of
them and the crew though less visible
than the cast were no less important we
had some amazing people working on this
show as all those Emmys bear witness
David and Dan assembled a championship
team the directors were incredible as
well I should start naming names but
then I'd miss someone there were so many
but I do need to mention David Benioff
Dan Weiss and Bryan cogman the third
head of the Dragon as I said in the
recent Vanity Fair piece about him and
of course the great team at HBO any
other network and Game of Thrones would
not have been what it became most other
networks this series never gets made at
all I could go on and on and have as
I've been writing this post in my head
but there's really too much to say
parting is such sweet sorrow The Bard
wrote in the weeks and months to come
I'm a post about some of my favorite
moments from the making of the show now
and again when I am feeling nostalgic
but just now there are so many memories
and no time to do them all justice let
me say this much last night wasn't
ending but it was also a beginning
nobody is retiring anytime soon David
and Dane are going on a Star Wars and
other projects beyond that Amazon
scooped up Bryan cogman and put him to
work on developing shows of his own as
well as helping out on their big Tolkien
projects our brilliant cast has
scattered to the four winds but you'll
be seeing a lot of them in the years to
come in all manners a television shows
and movies our directors are keeping
busy as well I suspect that you have not
seen the last of Westeros on your
television sets either but I guess that
all depends on how some of these
successor shows turn out and me I'm
still here and I'm still busy as a
producer I've got five shows in
development at HBO some having nothing
whatsoever to do with the world of
Westeros I have to at Hulu one on the
History Channel I'm involved with a
number of feature projects some based
upon my own stories and books and some
material created by others there are
these short films that I'm hoping to
make adaptions a classic stories by one
of the most brilliant quirky and
original writers our genre has ever
produced and I'm writing winter
coming I told you long ago and so it is
the winds of winter is very late I know
I know but it will be done I won't say
when I've tried that before only to burn
you all in jinx myself but I will finish
it and then will come a dream of spring
how will it end
I hear people asking the same ending as
the show different well yes and no and
yes and no and yes and no and yes I am
working in a very different medium than
David and Dan never forget they had six
hours for the final season I am
expecting these last two books of mine
well Phil 3000 manuscript pages between
them before I'm done and if more pages
and chapters and scenes are needed I'll
add them and of course the butterfly
effect will be at work as well those of
you who follow this not a blog will know
that I've been talking about this in
season one there are characters who
never made it onto the screen at all and
others who died in this show but still
live in the books so if nothing else the
readers will learn what happened to all
of the other characters book or show
which will be the real ending it's a
silly question how many children did
Scarlett O'Hara have how about this I'll
write it you read it then everyone can
make up their own mind and argue about
it on the internet so at the end of the
day I know I'm still very optimistic
about the future I believe we will get
the winds of winter very soon as well as
another show that is based on his a Song
of Ice and Fire universe like George
said Game of Thrones might be over but I
suspect this will not be the last time
that we visit Westeros on our
televisions so let me know what you
think about these updates leave me some
of your thoughts down below once again I
want to thank everyone for stopping by
to watch another video and I also want
to thank everyone for supporting the
channel I hope you have a great day I
will see you again very soon bye
you
[Music]
you